good morning
Millennials welcome back to the
test happy
Monday how's everybody
do you aren't doing your regular
intonations I'm not it's Monday Jack
it's the holiday season I don't know I'm
just feeling crazy you're feeling frisky
ever since you posted what you posted on
the gram yeah so let's talk about that
Theo is at radiation I didn't go this
week Ben went
let's start with Monday morning prayers
up for du that's important and just know
like I am giving everything I have to
Theo's treatment
and spiritually emotionally financially
we understand so I'm trying to change
Shake It Up Chicago maybe my new
intonation will bring more viewers bring
more Revenue yeah like this is a
business for sure okay I'm I'm I'm
always here for change you know that I'm
here for change what let me tell you
what I'm not here for my eye is still
twitching I know everyone's so done with
hearing about my eye twitch you guys
it's been what is it now like 3 four
weeks it's bugging the out of me so
here's the thing about the show we
welcome all complaints we do we think
it's necessary part of the human
experience and of the Jewish faith of
the Jewish faith and we want you to
complain however
like there's got to be like a cap I
agree there's got to be a cap on this
eye twitch and I'm being tested and I
don't know why and I think I might have
to get an eye patch and then of course
make it like my entire personality of
course I think Theo needs an ey patch
too and you guys can be twinning we just
be a family of pirates R matey are ready
kids I I turty I can't hear you I I
turty oh let's talk about the cultural
impact of that theme song I would love
to but there's something really
important that we have to talk about
this morning oh my God wait what let me
think I don't know if you're going to
guess what I'm thinking of there's
always so many things to talk about it's
so true thank God we have a daily
podcast especially on a Monday like
there was a long there was a lot of
weekend that happened but the thing that
I want to talk about primarily on
today's show is your experience with a
pet
psychic oh my god wow I totally forgot I
wasn't even going to bring it up I
literally I'm
obsessed I literally had such a weekend
I totally forgot yes I finally met with
a pet psychic yesterday and please share
with everyone what she said there was a
lot that she had said um you know I'm
not a I'm not a like a a firm believer
you know I'm not a skeptic like I do
feel like there are people out there who
have some sort of third eye I think
there's definitely there's Vibes there's
merits to the to the whole thing of
course I'm also a person who's you know
deeply rooted in reality so I try not to
take you know everything so everything
that she said so lit but you did engage
a pet psychic over Zoom yes which is a
choice yes and let me tell you that pet
psychic had a lot to say about Bruno she
did and to be
honest facts on facts on facts and now I
think I have to believe everything she
said she came for my boy I know what
you're thinking did you did she say
Bruno she means Theo no she came for
Bruno saying that Theo doesn't like
Bruno that Bruno eats his food and sits
on his couch yep where else is he
supposed to sit he I guess when Theo
came through like I know there's a lot
going on in Theo's life and I just
thought it was interesting it was worth
noting that you know for the first time
ever Theos had the ability to speak to
me directly to communicate and did he
want to talk about his cancer no did he
want to talk about as a pesky little
cousin yes yes and also there was
something else that she said that we've
been trying to interpret cuz it could
mean a number of different things so she
was really fixated on the she said Theo
is saying he misses his palm tree now
she was like do you have a palm tree in
your house maybe by the front door and I
said I've never had a plant in my home
in my entire life so that's not
it then I got to thinking about palm
trees now of course I realized I'm
sitting in front of a wallpaper full of
palm trees the toast didn't even cross
my mind at that point at that moment
what I had thought of was there's a
Jackie has a great backyard and whenever
me and Jack me and Theo stay there Theo
gets to roam free because you have a
totally fenced in backyard it's probably
the most Freedom offleash he ever really
gets I leave him out there for literally
hours he sniffs he one time had an
altercation with an iguana him and brudo
took on this big ass iguana it's kind of
I would say an important geographic
feature in Theo Theo's life would you
agree I would agree the Iguana had
brought our boys together it was a it
brought me together oh my God I was
freaking no one was up yet and so I took
Theo out and Bruno was mulling out in
the house I was like let me take both
the boys out I let them go they're
running and then they're both like doing
something in the corner of your backyard
I'm like let me see what's going on
there is an iguana who's bigger than
them like bigger than either one of them
who had obviously like climbed your
fence and was clearly stuck in your yard
he couldn't figure a way to get out your
yard is totally fenced in for the boys
and they went after him these two boys
went after the iguana and I didn't know
how to intervene because I thought it
was dangerous but what am I going to do
touch the Iguana like I was totally
helpless in that moment and no one was
awake and it was so scary not to make
their moment about me but like I was
really kind of triggered right but these
boys are Hunters they are hunters and
they are gatherers and they show that
iguana who's boss so all that to say
that is your backyard is very special
and to the boys yes and it's a positive
in Theo's life so you thought the palm
tree might have meant and you texted me
saying Theo wants to go to Jackie's
house like because there is this part of
your yard where there's like eight big
palm trees that create this sort of like
I don't know very uh picturesque very
vacationy very B Oasis Oasis yes and
it's one of my favorite parts of your
backyard it's very beautiful and they're
always you know running in and out of
the trees so I thought maybe that was
him saying he wanted to go to your house
but then someone else was like you know
palm trees are also a Cornerstone of the
toast so maybe he wants to get back to
normal life get back to work I don't
know it's confusing I like obviously the
first
Theory that's where my mind went come on
down anytime do laal la we would love to
have you
yeah open invitation so like I said
we're doing a bit of the East a bit of
the West a bit of the unknown today
Theo's at round two of radiation you did
a bit of the North Pole cuz you took him
to see the Christmas lights I did my
weekend was very theocentric you know we
got a stroller for him so we were able
to take him out of the house he's been
you know kind of Hol Up and Theo of
course he's a King Charles cavalier
they're known for being like indoor dogs
lap dogs if he never left the house like
it wouldn't be a big deal but Theo has
an adventur side I remember when we did
his DNA results it said he was was about
2% uh Neanderthal and what was his
wolfiness oh I'm sorry not Neanderthal
wolfiness he had 4% wolfiness and that's
via embark embark that was one of our
toast sponsors they're not a sponsor
anymore but it really was a fabulous we
did it it was like 23 and me for dogs
and they tell you their background and I
thought it was really interesting it is
very interesting so you've done a bit of
the East the West the North and now you
got to come South tury it's so true so
my weekend was very like heavy trying to
you know make him comfortable and I'm
hoping that today we'll be able to I
don't know if we'll know yet if
radiation or anything that we've been
doing has been helping I don't know if
they're going to do X-rays I do wish I
was there but like I said these are
expensive treatments and's got to work
Mommy's got to work yes so prayer is up
for du prayer is up for du and also the
psychic told you that he's not in pain
and so did the acupuncturist like do is
okay yes yes yes um
she did say like she could see him
making it to the spring and that's
really not what I was hoping for you
know I was hoping you know for spring of
2,100
right so that's why I'm really not like
wanting to believe everything she said
no obviously this whole exercise was a
Croc you also said that Ben was very
much leading her yeah that's the thing
that's like rule number one if you're
going to get engage a psychic like give
them nothing Poker Face how can you ever
know yeah yeah yeah it was good it was
good it was good no it sounded like a
Croc especially the part about my boy
Bruce no that was probably the most
legitimate part he was so hurt by these
allegations have you ever seen a psychic
I think I've stopped in you know on the
side of the road once but not like just
I don't know maybe out of boredom or
like not in a meaningful way not in a
meaningful way it's not a recommended
person just like oh let's get some tea
on me
yeah I do have a lot of interest in
seeing a medium I think that would be
interesting and it's just too bad that
when we interviewed Tyler Henry he said
he wasn't you know taking calls from the
Beyond damn he hung up the phone do you
remember that yeah I I forget why he
said he wouldn't do it he was like off
you know off the clock oh yeah but
Teresa Caputo's never off the clock he
hadn't had enough time to Google us you
know she's at the grocery store oh my
God would you look at that hunk uper
shoot who's the young men who pass
suddenly you know I do she never off the
clock no if like I were at a dinner
party and there were psychic like I'm
always going to hear them out I'm always
going to hear them out like what's like
really what's the downside if you don't
put too much of a personal stake in it
and don't make like actual serious
decisions based off what they say
exactly but I'm always open but you
can't lead them on Ru number one don't
give them anything it's true Ben was
definitely leading but you know I'm I'm
in this place in my life and it's kind
of the the place is called desperation
Nation where I am willing and open to
try anything so keep sending
recommendations okay yeah I get a lot of
inbounds like make sure tury sees this
and I see it Taylor ster has been she's
like people have been messaging me they
need to get this information to you I'm
just sending it your way I read
everything so thank you great so glad to
hear it how was your weekend my weekend
was great super busy lots of fun very
tiresome but good good I finished my
voice boys are great they miss their
dear auntie KOA I can't wait let
me just say that I can't wait to
see those kids those kids ain't going to
know what the hit those
kids they're not even going to know K
when hurricane COA comes swirling
through the living room they are not
going to know what's going on it could
be sooner if Theo has his way and yes I
am going to hit your kids with that COA
Spirit H nothing better no and Olivia
tell Olivia when next time you see her
tell her kids to get ready okay
I will we're scared well actually
hanukkah's this week which is really
exciting I've been planning I'm going to
make lotas for the first time I've never
made lotas I have really by yourself no
no with the great Mark shown wer oh
right of course I'm sure you like made
Mark do all the work and you took all
the credit uh Mark did do all the work
when he and I made um lotas together for
anyone who doesn't know Mark is my dear
friend who is the cutest man alive and
is a Holocaust Survivor and last
Hanukkah I went to his house he has a
kind of like a really special recipe um
and ever since then it's kind of like
ruined lotas for me General it's like
you're in Mark's thing yeah no and it's
like no lotka is ever going to be as
good as the one I made with Mark right
what's the recipe where can I find it
it's it's a shle recipe it's a recipe
from you know from back in the day it
goes
it yeah it's old school he had a special
like potato shredding machine that
literally looked like uh it was from
Back to the Future it was insane oh wow
well I in my printer I just printed a
recipe I had heard the New York Times
lodka recipe is very good hopefully it's
better than anything else that they do I
don't know how the New York Times could
have a good lka recipe when the New York
time ooes anti-Semitism do the lotas
come in swastika-shaped
designs no I don't think so but it would
make sense for them to like want to
profit off the not support by the way I
bet it's so good like that's there like
that's how far they're willing to go you
know to profit off of judism but if
anybody has a good lka recipe like I'm
not tied to anyone so you know what I
will ask Mark's daughters if they have
his written down they were so thin like
literally a cracker it was so good o
okay cool thanks yeah like premium so
I'm excited about that made some banana
bread yesterday too tasty stuff and I
read Britney Spears's Memoir because
we're recording the redheads today a new
episode drops on Thursday great book for
the end of the year such a quick read I
feel like I have a real a brief on
Britney and now when I see all these
stories about her in the towboys which
are every single day and I usually kind
of skip past cuz I'm just like giving
Britney like her space like whatever she
wants to do go and do it you've earned
the right we don't need to like pick it
apart and I feel that way also after
reading the book but just with more
context now on why she is the way she is
and it was just interesting so I'm
excited to recap the book with the
girlies and also it's our end of year
episode so we're doing top three books
of the Year redhead and non- redhead we
are um on the same cycle because I too
finished my celebrity Memoir and my book
club also meets this evening so tell me
cuz I don't want to spoil anything for
anyone but tell me like the juiciest
thing you
learned from Britney Spears's book and
I'll share like the juiciest thing I
learned from Matthew Perry's okay well
it's hard because a lot of like the big
things became news stories like the
abortion oh true
um I'm trying to
think
of other like things that I
didn't necessarily know
um juic is I don't know there was like
some Jam Lynn slander which of course
Jamie Lynn the sister not Jamie the dad
oh I mean there was so much all family
slander which was weird because then
also this weekend she was seen with her
mom but after having read the book like
she's written off her family but also
having read the book it's like I also
understand why she always goes back to
them cuz like that's just who she is
even as they were like completely
betraying her like she cared so much
about like what they thought of her um
Cade is in the book A Lot her agent and
he just was a really good friend to her
so that was really um nice to read and
it was interesting how she felt about
some of her songs and like what album
she considers like her best work and
also I guess it's also about like how
many albums sold but like she kept on
talking about Glory that that's her best
album and I need to like go back no you
probably have I need to like go back and
like look at all her songs but it was
the book felt like very brief in in
chronicling her career like she just
like one day is famous and huge and 200
million albums sold and it's like oh
okay how was that so I guess she wasn't
bothering people with that Journey no
she really wasn't it moved very quickly
which was nice yeah I would say the
juiciest part of Matthew Perry's novel
and maybe people know this but because
of my age like I wasn't aware of the um
like the context at the time but like
the things about friends like first that
they ended up being the highest paid
people on television and the reason that
they they got that was because David
Schwimmer when the show started was
probably he had like the most clout he
was like probably the most famous one
maybe him and Courtney Cox and he was
probably slated to um get paid the most
and he went to all the individual other
cast members and was like we should
negotiate as a team and had it not been
for him doing that like he could have
been greedy and and made more than
everyone else and it would have been
like fair but he decided that like
moving forward for the rest of the the
show that they would all be like one
solid unit in negotiating with the
network which I thought was interesting
I also didn't know that Jennifer Aniston
was the one who wanted the show to end
and that's and they all like kind of
agreed but she was the one who said it
and deci like decided it was over um and
I I I always gather this as like a
viewer of the show but like Joey's
character like made no sense in a lot of
different ways he was like this really
good-looking guy who was friends with
all these women like it just he was also
dumb like it his character was kind of
messy it never I I I couldn't even
Define like what his role was within the
group and like that was a general
feeling like everybody understood that
and they said by seasons 9ine and 10
like those were Joey's best seasons and
that's why Joey got the spin-off Joey
that lasted very very briefly but um I
always felt that was something like I
just felt not like that everyone else
did but apparently like they knew they
they couldn't figure out Joey as a
character how do we solve a problem like
a
joey exactly so if you're a friends fan
I I loved the book I think I I gave it
four out of five stars Joey reminds me
of Johnny Drama from
Entourage from my perch of barely
watching both shows well just because
they're both like desperate outof work
actors clowns yeah yeah Johnny Drama is
one of the greatest characters in
television history like they don't make
him like Johnny drama anymore yeah well
at least he got his justice so true yeah
um so two good memoirs what score did
you give Britney I gave it a
four same because I don't know that it
got deep enough I don't know that it was
meant to but I felt like she was talking
about things maybe expecting us to know
like from The Outsiders perspective like
I don't ever know what happened like why
she got put in the conservatorship like
she talks about how she was kind of like
going you know not not even wild she was
just like having fun living life kind of
living on the edge but still only ever
like drinking not even in a abusive way
just having fun sort of way and all of a
sudden like you know the hair shaving
and the umbrella and when she described
those things I was able to understand
how she got to that point of the hair
shaving and the umbrella especially like
all the rage against the paparazzi but
to get have things get so bad with her
family I I just like it didn't I didn't
there were chunks missing yeah or yeah I
don't know but maybe if I had been a
little older at the time I would be like
oh I could put it together
yeah you know what I mean so yeah not
that anyone ever deserves to have that
happen to them but it's like that that
didn't happen the first 10 years of her
career like what really changed but she
was also going through a lot but still
it was just like a drastic measure to
take yeah yeah yeah so I really couldn't
even tell you why they why they did that
in a like other than the fact that like
Jamie Spears is very controlling man his
father was a very controlling abusive
man that's obviously like the thread
that they drew that got he was like
abused by his dad and like he was doing
those same things to Britney like very
very controlling of her
um beside that I don't know what Britney
she said she like drove like to the edge
of a cliff like in a fun way and like
was like you know just adrenaline
rushing yeah a conservator ship yeah you
know like how did we get there how did
we get out how did we get out I mean she
thanked the fans so much she was in like
a institution uh mental facility when
and no one knew she was there and she
couldn't communicate with anyone and one
of the nurses there like showed her
online like people like doing like free
Britney stuff for the first time and how
it meant so much to her that like
somehow her fans knew that she wasn't
okay and that's like what got the ball
rolling uh and also her kind of you know
invest like taking a chance on herself
and finding a new lawyer and deciding
like I'm going to get out of this
because also they hadn't put her in an
institution until then where she
couldn't get out and she's like giving
blood once a week and and going like in
bed from like 9: to 9: and can't do
anything doesn't have a God yeah so that
that was like rock bottom of the
conservatorship but also like then her
fans like sense and I do remember it
being that way where like there were a
lot of Hardcore fans that were like
what's going on with Britney where is
Britney free Britney yeah and she like
that's exactly what it was no it's it's
one of those very few rare instances
where like the internet's Instinct was
like right on the pulse of what was
really going on yeah and like it happens
all the time and people are always wrong
you know they're like I think this but
it really was true and it galvanized the
entire fandom yeah and and they really
created real change also I have
questions about Kevin
Federline okay because he in the book
like not a good husband you know use the
kids against her he got so much more
custody than she did to at this present
moment in time does she see her sons why
do I feel like there was drama where her
sons were like talking about her
yeah no she doesn't see her sons they
one of them just turned 18 so um he's
not like a minor anymore but the other
lives with Kevin and theyve decided they
don't want to see Britney it's just so
like when she was a mom I didn't realize
she had two kids in two years she had
her first son and got pregnant 3 months
later like that's really close together
and so she's like has a newborn and and
is pregnant carrying her babies like
there's all that footage of her like
when she like tricks like she's
literally pregnant holding a child with
like thousand shutter flashes around her
like that's not anyways she loves her
son so much like everything she did was
like to try and get time with them but
like how did this
loser get her kids over her like when at
one point she's the most powerful like
pop artist in the world I don't know how
you can like see that much power even
though it was taken from her I know you
know I don't know enough about like the
whole Britney Kevin situation and I know
that the Britney fans like hate Kevin
they think he's like a couch potato Who
cashes Britney's checks for child
support and I'm sure that he does but
there is you know it is worth noting
that like while Britney was struggling
like they had a dad who to who who took
care of them you know and I I think
there's Merit in that and like yeah he
doesn't work and he cashes Britney's
checks but those kids are alive and well
and there's there's value in that so I
think he gets like a lot of hate and I'm
sure some of it is warranted but I do
think not enough people talk about the
fact like for many years Britney was
unable due to her health to be a fully
present mom and like their dad was there
for them and I don't know I think like
not enough people talk about that but I
also don't know enough about it yeah I
just don't know enough about it it's
like why did he want she was always
worried when she met him she found out
later that he had one small child and a
child on the way and so she was worried
that he was going to leave her when her
kids were little which is exactly what
he did but then why did he want them so
badly like that didn't seem Accord is it
just so that he would get the child
support and like that was his income and
job inome it's possible she didn't say
that but see these are the things I'm
like trying to piece together that I
don't fully understand and then he did
raise them Prime like with more custody
than she did she had no and as as they
got older they chose to live with him so
there's something to be said for you
know for that yeah but also there was an
incident with Jamie Spears the dad he
like got abusive towards one of them so
then they got a restraining order
against him and so if the dad was
conservative over Britney and always
around Britney then Britney couldn't be
around him oh yeah yeah yeah yeah there
so a kind of left with a lot of
questions still but a general outline of
the last 40 years got it interesting
yeah um so we're going to dive in if
that's okay with you always okay with me
without further a did it do about Do's
trip to the pet psychic here are the
fast side stories that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
papaya reusables as you know Jackie and
I are very popular and we have a laundry
list of people to buy holiday gifts for
but it's not stressful ask me why Jack
why is that tury L we found a holiday
gift for everyone in our life no matter
age gender personality type and they're
going to be obsessed ooh color me
intrigued what is it papaya reusable
paper towels we've been using them for
months and we already introduced them to
the toasters but now it's time for
everyone on our list I agree I'm
planning on giving them to a few of my
friends who are homemaking girlies they
don't even realize how much they need
them in their life here are the basics
one sheet replaces 17 rolls of
disposable paper towels and whenever I
hear that fact I'm shook each set comes
with a cute little hook you'll hang it
on your backsplash in your or maybe in
your bathroom and then when you have a
mess to clean up you don't have to grab
a million paper towels just grab the
papaya rinse it in the sink and hang it
back up next time to dry because I don't
want to touch a roll of paper towels or
clean with a disgusting stinky rag ever
again papaya is it for cleaning and ever
since I moved into my house I've been
trying to maintain like that fresh just
smoothed in clean feeling so I've been
using it on everything it's very
versatile if you're looking for a last
minute holiday gift papaya is for
everyone they're going to love it and
you're going to look like a good person
so it's a win-win now you're saying chy
I already bought all my holiday gifts
calm down just buy some papaya for
yourself then it's almost the new year
so it's the perfect time to change
habits stop using disposable paper
towels and make an eco-friendly switch
that you're going to love the discount
is fabulous because the team of papaya
are huge toasters so they're always
giving you guys the best deals go to
papaya reusables tocom right now use
code toast for 30% off sitewide that's
papaya reusables tocom and use code
toast for 30% off papaya is just one of
those products that until you actually
try it you're like okay that just sounds
like a rag but once you hang them up
around your house and start using them
it's like yeah I get the hype now papaya
reusables tocom today's episode is also
brought to you by manscaped ladies today
we're we're being Santa's number one
helper the holiday season go beyond the
boring gifts and the stuffy stuffing
stocking stuffers and get something that
your man actually needs the performance
package 5.0 for manscaped the ultra the
Ultimate Grooming bundle is designed to
treat his special snowflake give the
gift of joy and Perfection and slay the
holiday down with 20% off and free
shipping at manscape.com manscape is
just the go-to place for everything
grooming for the man in your life so
also I use recently on Theo so really
any man in your life grooming Essentials
ear and nose trimmers everything you
could possibly need comes in this
performance package 5.0 Ultra for
manscaped so that's the lawn mower it's
the ultra body trimmer the weed whacker
which is for nose and ear hair they are
both waterproof you can use it in the
shower um they also have after shave
lotion in there an anti-chafe ball
deodorant the gift of manscape doesn't
stop there the bundle comes with two
free gifts manscaped boxers and the shed
2.0 toiletry bag cuz men men need
pouches and I feel like pouches are for
the girls but manscaped understands like
pouches are also for the boys get 20%
off and free shipping when you use code
toast at manscape.com that's 20% off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use code toast his balls will be singing
Baby It's Cold Outside this is actually
really the perfect size for a stocking
stuffer it's also just a great gift use
code toast manscaped.com today's episode
is also brought to you by liquid IV no
matter where or how you're hydrating
this season liquid IV is the hydration
brand fueling your well-being and their
hydration multiplier can keep you going
through the end of the year and and
Beyond with three times the electrolytes
of the leading sports drink plus eight
vitamins and nutrients for everyday
Wellness liquid IV hydrates two times
faster than water alone all in a single
stick now it's available in sugarfree
and you can choose from three delicious
flavors white peach green grape and
lemon lime I love lemon lime I also feel
like the end of the year like we've all
just pretty much given up on
productivity liquid IV is making sure
that's not going to happen like no
crashes you'll feel good you'll be
hydrated no midday migraine brains we
are getting through to the end of the
year and we're going to Slay Slay the
house down you know with liquid IV one
stick of liquid IV and 16 ounces of
water hydrates better than water alone
with three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink no artificial
sweeteners and zero sugar it has eight
vitamins and nutrients for everyday
Wellness always have one in your purse
if you're traveling if you have a
hangover if you're just not feeling well
have it in your purse it will save your
life one day and you'll be like thanks
tury l so grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide
at Costco Shapiro approved or you can
get 20% off when you go to liquid i.com
and use code toast at checkout so it's
20% off anything you order when you shop
better hydration using promo code toast
at liquid i.com this is just a product
you want to have in your house always
throw one in your purse keep it in the
cabinet I really like the lemon lime
flavors but flavors are personal so
choose what you like but I like lemon
lime tastes like like a soda it's really
good um and just have it stocked you
never know when you need one after a
long night just long day midday crash
check it out thank you L Del you're
welcome you're welome our first
story it's always the first story on a
Monday usually it's true it's tailored
and Travis Taylor went to Wisconsin to
see her mans take on the Green Bay
Packers she was and lose and lose this
was the first game she was in in
attendance where they lost so she'll
obviously have to be there for him a
shoulder to cry on I think he's going to
cry some big fat tears cuz honestly like
it they lost but like Travis also like
played poorly oh he did did you watch
the game I did and literally there was
two minutes left and I turned to bed I'm
like where is Travis like I literally
didn't even see him and it was a very
interesting day of football because the
Eagles and the Chiefs both lost so I saw
that the Eagles played the 49ers which
is a really big game and I think that'll
probably be their conference
Championship because they're like the
best in their leagues and it was last
year and the 49ers won I love that I'm
so happy for them not only did they win
they slay the house down but I don't
know why I feel like that means the
Eagles are going to win next time cuz
they're like extra hungry for it so I
said the same thing to bed um but they
were they had the home game the Eagles
like they had the home field advantage I
think maybe next time it'll be in San
Francisco like is that how it works I
feel like the eagles like they thrive in
more of an underdog situation like when
they're on top they they don't know what
to do like it's like you know the he oh
he said in his Super Bowl speech like h
hungry dogs eat first or something like
that like that's their they're Scrappy
they're Scrappy they don't want to be
like you know big fat high on the hog no
I I agree big fat high in the hog is
like so
Chiefs yeah like always winning we stay
winning like Patriots they are not that
and I just think it's worth noting like
the Eagles have lost two games this
season to both of my teams the 49ers and
the Jets that's insane that they lost to
the Jets no it's just kind of like one
of my favorite fun facts about this
current NFL season that I bring up
probably once a week are you sure that's
true positive that's insane they're like
11 and two or 10 and two whatever even
if the Jets do nothing else of note this
year like that's insane but the Jets
won't do nothing else of note this year
because did they lose yesterday yes did
they score a touchdown even no but is
December 24th three weeks away yes and
rumors are swirling that Mr State of
Grace will be making a grand return yes
can't wait I can't okay I can't wait for
that so Eagles 49ers I actually feel
like the Eagles have a better chance of
winning the next time they play because
they lost yeah no I know they have
something to prove like and they love
having something to prove that's just
like I know I thought the same I
literally said the same thing to Ben I'm
like I kind of wanted you know the
Eagles to win just so that next time
like check in the boys they just lit up
M they're matter yeah rub some dirt in
it so the only loss that's really kind
of like a big L is the Chiefs what are
you doing no and the Packers are like
not a bad team by any means but they're
not like there's like an elite upper
echelon of teams right now it includes
like the eagles the 49ers the Chiefs and
like I think maybe there's one other
team that's doing really well oh the
Detroit I just feel like I wouldn't have
included like Green Bay in there like
green at this point wasn't even yeah and
Green Bay at this point like wasn't even
slated to make the playoffs so like what
are you doing yeah and Taylor's there
she came all this way she brought her
plane and her friend friends and her a
coat and he
stunk yeah not not cool not cool but
let's talk about tailored and Britney
and I feel like this was the first game
she went to where there wasn't like a
lot of news there wasn't a lot of photos
or videos yeah I wonder maybe like the
culture in g bay they just like didn't
really care as much cuz it wasn't a home
game no way like why they were like
putting up signs like we're here for
Simone biles cuz her man plays for the
Green Bay Packers yeah no and I love
that and I'm here for some biles too but
like they didn't put her on TV a lot
like there just wasn't a lot of content
that came out of it yeah but people are
speculating that she bared Britney
Mahomes coat she definitely did but the
girl next to her was also wearing the
same coat oh maybe like one of the
chief's Wags has like a a a coat line of
a line of coats yeah I thought the girl
next to her she was blonde she was
wearing the exact same coat I thought
she might have been a body double I
don't like the coat so the fact that
maybe three different people purchased
it as opposed to you know everyone
sharing is shocking I I I don't like I'm
I'm not into like big coats like with no
and that that fuzzy material that's not
fur I'm literally wearing what I'm
wearing today too yeah Teddy Vibes I'm
actually not I think it makes like I'm
wearing something like it and I think it
makes me look like I think it's
unflattering no but also Teddy Vibes in
red yeah know it like it it reminds me
of Clifford it's giving Clifford I have
the same thought I guess like it's red
for the Chiefs so we must accept it she
looks awesome and I love the bun I'm for
the bun I loved the boots like it was a
cute look for sure I do wonder if it's
Britney's coat they like they seem
really tight and Taylor's been in Kansas
City Britney blew with her did she on
air Swift I mean airswift greater than
every other Airline on the planet I
would give my right arm and then they
jetted out immediately after game I mean
why would they stick around but they
made it seem like like she skipped
dipped out cuz they lost which she
obviously did what was she going to
spend the night in Wisconsin she's going
home to Kansas City right to Travis's
house I'm assuming yeah well if Britney
was with her they flew I don't know if
they F home together oh maybe she just
needed a ride there I'm sure they did
everything together honestly except why
did they part ways when they were
backstage I'm so glad you brought that
up because they spent the the game
together in the same box but the video
we had gotten of Taylor entering the
arena from like the backstage you know
underground entrance she walks in with
Britney and then they literally give
each other a kiss on the cheek and part
ways yeah it's like Taylor had to go
through a separate entrance I know why
because at the beginning of games
because I went once with like with a wag
there is um like the families go on the
field before kickoff and like say hi to
their husbands and stuff you like stand
behind this rope and their husband like
you always stand in the same place and
your husband comes and finds you um and
it's like so cute that's where all the
girles like take the cute pictures
Olivia cpos I was doing it and then you
go up to your seats and Taylor's not
doing that yet yet I don't I don't think
Taylor would ever do it honestly I think
for her to be on a stad on a field with
so many other people is like actually a
security issue like one of the fans
could literally just jump down and like
I don't think she would ever do it even
if they're married with kids but what if
her kids want to go yeah I guess we'll
cross that bridge when we get there no I
think in the course of their
relationship it will happen at least
once I mean I can't say any like every
time I make a prediction I'm wrong like
this has been so unpredictable okay well
I feel like every time I make a
prediction I'm wrong too so it's like if
we make opposite predictions one of us
has to be
right okay it increases our odds we
should do that for everything then the
toast is always right yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's seven years in how are we just
thinking of this because we're really
not like the type of people who like
make pop culture predictions I don't
care if my predictions come true or not
like I'm just having fun you know and
also like I'm so authentic that I really
like if if I have a gut feeling on a
prediction like I'm sharing what I
actually think not you know trying to
increase my odds in Vegas no and I'm so
authentic that
like this show is reflective of my
personality and my brand and my brand
like is being dumb and wrong all the
time like sorry yeah I'm just that
authentic you love to see it
authenticity at its finest so that's
your football recap for the weekend
Taylor and Travis going strong now
she'll be there for him in low of
his it's not been the greatest few weeks
for them and her but I think they're
there for each other and that's what
matters yeah I think so too I think the
fact that she came to the game you know
public you know publicly facing showed
up for her man I think it's good yeah
agreed are you ready for our next story
yeah Jerry Turner the golden Bachelor is
um no
is standing up for himself dismissing
the weight shaming claims he said he
really doesn't have time to think about
it oh also I wanted to say it was
spoiled for me too I saw I'm so sorry I
saw the name and then like I saw the two
of them sitting down for an interview so
like now I'll recognize her too me
too yeah but uh golden Bachelor star
Jerry Turner seemingly BW off claims
that he allegedly broke up with his
ex-girlfriend due to her weight game he
told the LA Times I don't have time to
reflect on comments like this my only
response is that I have so many positive
things in my life right now I have the
wonderful love of blank blank spoiled
again my
partner he shared adding that he is
happy to look forward also in the
interview he did kind of talk about the
claim that he hadn't dated since his
wife and was like you know I guess that
is untrue but we have different it's
very like subjective what dating and
being in a relationship
means yeah um one thing about me like
I'm not cancelling Gary like I'm not can
G Gary and I also kind of love like when
you're 72 years old and like you know
thyself like you you don't have a hard
time standing up for yourself no and
this is what's refreshing about like the
golden Bachelor is the crop of people
and the the talent isn't your typical
you know 22-year-old influencer on the
rise like where you oh I'm sorry like
Gary doesn't give a yeah no we're
not getting a video from Gary we're not
getting a Notes app screenshot like Gary
does Gary don't give a Gary is not
listening he's not learning Gary is not
over party Gary is not over party so
that's a party I'll go to me too I think
I'll wear this hat to the party tonight
you should Gary would love
it Gary would love it Gary would love
everything because Gary's a nice guy and
that's all you get when you do the
golden
Bachelor I can't believe like we
literally and this is actually one of
our predictions that did come true true
we said that people were going to like
dig up Gary's old tweets I honestly
didn't think they would travel to
Indiana and find like the cocktail
waitress who saw him on a date one time
thus disproving he never dated after his
wife died I didn't think they would go
that deep but the depravities of the
current state of Journalism never ceased
to amaze me no and the depravities and
links they had to go to get something on
Jerry just for me underscores that he
must be an amazing man that like this
was it this was the worst of Gary right
he was actually installing hot tubs when
he said he was retired like oh I'm so
sorry he wants to work yeah he's boy
with a job get your ass up and
work and that's what Kim was talking
about like exactly she was talking about
Gary speaking of Kim did you see this
for laoren Balenciaga show # collab with
aan like the bar is low the outfits were
low terrible I I guess everyone has just
officially moved on from Balenciaga like
the like the the elites people have not
if anyone who wears Balenciaga or
promotes Balenciaga you look at the
comments the people are still here yes
also I went shopping a few weeks ago and
it was holidays so like everything is
you know Buzzy and there was one bag I
was in like the designer section there
was one Sal shelf and it was all
Balenciaga bags the people are not happy
with Balenciaga still every time I um
walk or drive past the Balenciaga store
in the city I always I'm just like
Curious I have not seen a human being in
there since this whole thing happened
like seriously and at the beginning had
police standing outside for a while yeah
no I don't think anyone's going to do
anything crazy in the store aside from
like not want to buy their things and it
also doesn't help that their things like
every time I see Kim wearing it it's so
ugly oh yeah her outfit was really ugly
I will say like that little bag with the
bee on it yeah it's cute it comes in
every color so whatever your favorite
color is like you could get one maybe if
things had gone differently for Braga at
some point I might have gotten it in
pink it's a good evening bag it's yeah
it's just a it's a cute bag so so that's
a loss but those outfits are not no it's
like enough with the sweatshirts and the
spandex like it's so ugly yeah and it's
like you can get that anywhere it
doesn't have to be and I don't know just
doing it as like a collab with aroan
when I think of aroan now is like it's
so tick tocky it's like it's so
influencer and I think not I mean I love
influencers but I think they're beneath
Balenciaga like actually I actually now
no but you know what I mean but like the
fact that Kim was like she was like a
meme with her Aran bag yeah it was so
like basic and uninspired basic was the
word I was going to use yeah I was
shocked at that too there was also
another fabulous event in La last night
one of those Academy of things yes and I
will move it to our next story because
that fake event where everyone just
looks gorgeous and takes pictures but we
don't know what we're celebrating
happened last snipe it's called The
Academy Museum Gala but that's new that
I haven't heard of that one a couple
times a year there are these things and
their names are familiar to me LACMA
lachma is only becoming familiar because
they keep pushing it I never heard of
this one and I've never this carpet
didn't look familiar to me at allia this
happens every year remember we saw those
pictures of like Ka Gerber and that was
lachma that was LMA positive LA and
Austin Butler yes okay this one is the
academy Museum Gala at the Academy
Museum of Motion Pictures in Los Angeles
so it's like an Oscars like sounds like
a pre-oscars type of event no it's like
I don't even know if there's an event I
think it's just like pictures on a
carpet and then everyone goes home like
I I seriously think this is a
front I it's a money laundering scheme
I've never heard of this event but you
see the pictures are like so Kendall was
there Haley Bieber they look gorgeous
like I feel like they both looked
stunning I feel like it's just an event
for people to get their pictures um yeah
and then I don't know what happens on
the inside if there even was an inside
right like where does the carpet lead to
there's nothing behind them no I know
it's this is it's giving industry plant
it's a
front yeah let me search for more
information Academy Museum usually
usually we'll see like a couple photos
from the inside after party right right
on
Instagram and remember that time that
Lady Gaga went we were like what is this
she went to LMA I don't know is it LMA
no there are a few events every year
that like genuinely confuse me but the
roster is so A-list that you're forced
to pay attention and that's what
happened with LACMA so now when LACMA
happens once a year I'm like oh yeah
it's the LACMA thing yeah but then there
was that other event in New York the
other week what was
that yes there was there was um I don't
know what it was but a lot of fash thing
but it wasn't
cfda I thought it was like a TV thing I
don't know I don't know either um I'm
looking at more pictures from the event
and it's just it goes this carpet leads
to Nowhere there's no other people on
the carpet there's no one behind you
they're not going anywhere it's giving
Black
Mirror yeah well everyone who goes looks
great of course they do that's the point
and then they go home but what is it
it's probably like a great night out for
a celeb like you don't actually have to
go to the event you just get your photo
taken and then you get to like go to in
and out and go home yeah or like go to
catch in their nice dress Sushi Park
Sushi Park that sounds good what are you
having for lunch oh my God I was
actually think about that on the way
over here cuz I woke up particularly
hungry I had the probably the biggest
meal of my life last night what' you
have I went to um Reserve cut which is
like probably the best kosher restaurant
in the city it's all the way down in the
financial district so like I never go
and I've probably been three times in my
life and every time I'm there I'm like I
should go more but um I pretty much ate
everything that was put in front of me I
had for on appetizer short rib
brisket in a
taco I had crispy rice spicy
tuna then I had a big ass fet minan with
some french fries and then I had a
chocolate cake wow I'm so jealous I had
a hot dog oh that's disgusting why like
I don't know hot dog that's rude by the
way dog by the way that's
rude you
I said I'm jealous cuz you had a four
course meal and I had a hot dog you said
it like it was bad so I was just playing
along with like your energy no my energy
wasn't my energy wasn't disgusting
that's why yucking someone's yums tury I
feel as though hot dogs cooked at home
like are never good grilled on a
barbecue I don't think that they're ever
good yeah at a baseball game honestly on
the street corner with the crowd and the
I could see it being good you know chil
Street chili con carne dog like I could
see that I don't know like cookie one up
in your house it's on the grill outside
it's weird to me that's weird to me that
weird to you well I guess we're just
weird girls that you would yuck a yum
and you know how much I love hot dogs
but I was just saying like my meal was
you
know I literally was just like playing
off of your energy like searching for
victimhood much like my God I'm not I'm
just pointing out Bad Manners much
Jackie you're beneath this sort of
conver honestly you're beneath this no
you're talking about your filet Minun
and your short rib
tacos and I was just saying like I had a
singular hot dog I disgusting is a bit
of hyperbole you're beneath that this
this conversation is hyperbolic like are
you okay you stole my
word you stole my phrase you stole my
phrase first what was your phrase
beneath you beneath
me I can't with
you you can't with me because you're
wrong let's get back to the task at hand
what are you having for lunch let's get
down to business to
defeat the Han um what am I having for
lunch I don't know I I really I don't
know me
neither actually I just had like an
inspired idea what let me just see if
any of my friends who were like usually
available for lunch like want to want to
get lunch they want to lunch with
you I need to think cuz I feel like if I
wanted some of my lunch might need
planning but I don't think I'm going to
order something
right I love lunch what's your favorite
meal of the day would you
say like dinner dinner is my favorite
too but like what's your reasoning
behind it that I just have enough time
to ant like whatever I want I have
enough time to anticipate it and get it
or make it versus like it's already
lunch time I have I've made no plans
I've made no Arrangements yeah lunch
kind of creeps up on you and then you're
like waiting for dinner yeah I like
dinner because like in my current health
Journey like I dinner is where I kind of
just like up you know I try to
be good during the whole day and then
dinner's like let's go balls to the wall
yeah great yeah are you ready for it is
great are you ready for our next story
it is great and no I'm not ready for our
next story you don't look ready do you
want to ask me why why cuz our next
story is brought to you by Etsy so it's
the holiday season and we want to talk
to you about Etsy if you're like us
you're on a mission to find handcrafted
affordable gifts made by independent
sellers well whether you're searching
for custom home pieces like cutting
boards Linens throw pillars pillows for
your favorite holiday host or personal
items like purses necklaces and seasonal
jackets for your most stylish friend
friends or family Etsy has it and let me
tell you I had gotten really creative
for holidays this year cuz of our secret
Santa and Etsy was my first place that I
went to lur Deo same and I would tell
you guys what I got on Etsy but I don't
want to spoil secret santa but I would
not have been able to get a dynamic
wonderful secret santa present without
Etsy that's for damn sure and if you
have like a crazy idea for a gift just
like go to Etsy somebody's making it
yeah it's so good from like anything
from home to Fashion I Al a lot of
people were wondering where I got my
Halloween um costume I got it from a
vintage store on Etsy Etsy like is the
place for for gifts like if you have
something unique and you don't know
where like where should I start etsy.com
even if you have a person and you like
okay I know what they like just start
typing things into Etsy like there are
people there along with you they'll give
you ideas like Etsy is where we're going
for holiday shopping gifts that are
personal and gorgeous and unique and
special and meaningful Etsy has it for
all budgets and any gifting Mission so
if you're new to Etsy use code holiday
10 for 10% off your first purchase
that's holiday 10 maximum discount value
of $50 expires December 31st 2023 see
terms at etsy.com terms check it out
today's episode is also brought to you
by Mattress Firm when you sleep on the
right mattress everything just becomes
clear and Mattress Firm is the place to
go they have great sales especially this
time of year and your mattress is
arguably the most important thing in
your home like it's where at least for
me it's my desk it's my obviously my
sleeping place it's also my kitchen like
it's everything to me and my mattress is
from Mattress Firm they carry so many
fabulous Brands mine is Temperpedic and
I did buy it at one of their fabulous
sales like the one going on right now
there's so many great reasons to shop at
Mattress Firm specifically you could
shop in store or
online um but they have so many you know
great offerings like 120 nights to make
sure it's right for you or you get your
money back they also carry a wide
selection of high quality mattresses
from top brands at every price point and
they will find you the right mattress
from a wide selection whether you're a
parent you know your sleep can decline
in the first months postpartum children
can affect your sleep pattern sleep
plays a key role in our emotional
well-being especially during Parenthood
if you travel a lot it can disrupt your
starcadian Rhythm the holidays can throw
your sleeping habits through a loop so
the stress of people coming into town
getting stuff for everyone on your list
it can keep you up late at night so shop
in store or online to find the right
mattress at mattressfirm.com you could
take advantage of their major deals on
top of Brands during mattress firms
Black Friday sale shop in store or
online at mattressfirm.com that's
mattressfirm.com there's really never a
bad time to invest in your wellness and
Mattress Firm understands that that's
why they have an amazing sale going on
right now so check it out thanks La
you're welcome fa our next Story one of
our favorite girlies is a married woman
uh who let me think who got
married I didn't know until I checked
the stories this morning it was pretty
lowkey who Vanessa hudgin oh I got a
People notification about it this
morning morning married professional
baseball player Cole Tucker in Mexico so
Vanessa and her fiance said I do on
Saturday in tum sources confirmed to
people over the weekend a photo surfaced
on X of her posing on the beach barefoot
in a casual white dress which fueled
speculation that she said celebrated her
wedding her former HSM co- armer n
Coleman posted a video on her Instagram
story showing footage of a tropical
setting in tum oh I'd love that um
Taylor was there yes her BFF Gabriella
and Taylor together so what is the
status of her relationship with Ashley
Tisdale because Ashley Tisdale is really
tight with Austin Butler best friends
and I think things got weird right so
I'm assuming she wasn't there I don't
know we don't know much about this
wedding because it was all very lowkey
and it's all coming out slowly so maybe
she was there and we'll find out soon
stay tuned I hate to be that person cuz
I'm really happy that she's moved on but
like I'm I my feet stand firmly like in
the era of Austin Butler and Vanessa
hudgin like I just I I think it's wrong
like I think it's wrong what happened it
is wrong what happened I stand firmly
with Vanessa hudkins and Zack Efron like
you can't watch High School Musical and
tell me that those two aren't meant to
be together forever like it hurts to
watch it's like watching Twilight like
Edward and Bella like the love that they
have for each other and I actually think
this is more because they were a little
bit more like PDA about it they were
obsessed with each other and I just
don't see why it can't couldn't work
today between them like now when I look
at Kristen seart and Robert Paton I'm
like yeah you two no yeah not well one
of them yeah yeah yeah no no no I mean
she's like the gay so obviously like
it's not even in the realm of
possibility right so no no no it's not
going to happen I I do still feel
sadness I do want to say but like
Vanessa hudgin and Zack Eon I feel like
they could like be a new couple that we
reported on like they are
still right another they're right for
what I mean of course she's now you know
happily married to someone else and I
it's not what you want to hear the day
after your wedding but like right
hopefully she's not listening because
it's how I feel this is my truth so I'm
so glad you brought up Zack Efron
because you know Matthew Perry had said
like when he dies and if there's ever
like a biopic about him he wants Zack
Efron to play him in a movie I think
they really connected on 17 again and I
thought it was interesting that Matthew
Perry didn't bring up 17 Again in his
book because he talked a lot about the
work that he did after friends friends
and how like because of his um he became
kind of just like nobody wanted to work
with him so we started writing a lot and
so we talked a lot about his post
friends career and I would argue that 17
Again was at least commercially one of
his biggest successes after friends yeah
but then at the end of his book he had a
little Montage of photos of moments that
he had referenced in the book and he had
a a photo of him from 17 again and he
wrote a little blurb about how the um
the reviews were not good for his
performance in that movie and people
said he looked tired and he was like I
was supposed to look tired yeah that was
the point but also now that I think
about the movie it's like his character
was the main character but him as an
actor wasn't because he gets replaced by
Zack Eon pretty early
on when he becomes 17 again oh yeah so
is Matthew Perry like not in the middle
of the movie is he just in the beginning
of the end
yeah oh yeah the whole point is that
like he hates his life and he's like
tired of it and that's why he looks yeah
but then he becomes 17 Again early on
and then he only comes back at the end
so that's a great movie it is a great
movie but that's also probably why he's
not the main if if the movie like was
nominated for an Oscar he wouldn't be
best actor he might not even be best
supporting because that other guy is
that funny guy and then also the wife is
that Leslie man yeah she's great that's
a great movie Michelle
tractenberg oh my God Michelle
tractenberg th by the way thus fueling
my conspiracy theory about who the
black bald Michelle tractenberg what
happened to # where in the world is
Michelle tractenberg we have to have her
on the toast we need to be doing the
important interviews we have to have her
on the toast like that's what the world
means that Georgina
Sparks ex Ice Princess X7 again on the
toast X Harriet the Spy Harriet the
Spy no she's an immensely talented
person I hope she's really happy let's
check her
Instagram does she have Instagram I hope
maybe she wasn't blacklisted maybe she
left this toxic industry to find
peace well I'm all about that maybe
she's with Addison Ray Addison Ray was
at the event last night the lakma
academy Lama looking like Perfection
Perfection Perfection okay she does have
Instagram is she active she is
active what's the last thing she posted
a
selfie that says naughty or nice list oh
so somewhat recently 21 hours ago oh
obsessed I should follow her I don't
know if if you're going to there's a lot
of
art some some Harry Potter
comedy was she in Harry Potter I think
it's Harry Potter no I think she's just
a
fan
relatable it's my relatable
Queen what was the story van hudin is
married woman oh so yeah like I'm happy
I am but there is like a sadness
inevitable and inevitable
sadness terrible sadness actually also
like I know she was engaged and I know
that like this is what happens when
people are in relationships and engaged
but to me the fact that Vanessa hudgin
is a married woman I just didn't see it
for her no and I'm just I don't know
it's not right like it's not right I it
just it doesn't feel right to me I can't
explain it no I know it just doesn't but
because it feels so wrong it makes me
feel like it is right for her because
she like is kind of going against the
grain with this no and I we we love a
girl who marches to the beat of Her Own
Drum like we love however just for me it
doesn't feel right and I feel like
Vanessa hin is on every carpet at every
event doing everything like is she G to
start she should have been at LACMA no
is she going to start to bring her
husband
it's like such a drag you know I'm
not I don't know it just it doesn't feel
right and he's a baseball player yeah
and I love someone who has his own thing
like there's Major League um I do
believe there was a minor moment the
Pirates yeah but I think he made it back
to the majors he's currently on the
Albuquerque
Isotopes oh so I don't know it just
doesn't feel right which is my MLB my
lb excuse me MB I believe that means
minor that would make a lot of sense oh
yeah or like major inal league baseball
or something it's m lowercase i it's
minor um so maybe he goes like up and
down I don't know it just doesn't feel
right you know oh and by the way the
Pirates are major
league is he on the Pirates Pittsburgh
Pirates no and but he played for them so
he go I think he goes up and down yeah
yeah yeah which is you know the life of
lot of uh professional
athletes actually I was watching the
game last night it's like the saddest
thing happened the Chiefs vers oh man I
like actually this is why I can't watch
football because I'm such an empath
right so the Chiefs game it was like
towards the end it was very high stakes
the Green Bay team was punting the ball
so you know one guy kicks it and
everybody runs and one of the guys
running
fell
no one of the guys running like they
threw a flag down because he ran too
fast like he crossed the line before the
kicker he was Eager Beaver and they were
saying like this guy just got picked up
off the practice squad so it's like your
first big day and you're breaking like
the dumbest rule like calm down like I
felt so like I I had to turn the game
off like I felt so sad and like
empathetic like I just knew this was
like such a big deal for him like he
finally got off the practice squad I
feel like getting on the practice squad
is like it's such a bummer as a
profession like it's a part of just Prof
a lot of the professional athletes
career and to get off is like and like
your first day back you're like
literally breaking one of like the most
amateur rules I I felt really sad and
it's like because he was so e Eager
Beaver because he just got off the
practice squad like he couldn't wait one
more second no I know and so the his
team did win so hopefully like they just
sweep it under the rug and like chalk it
up to Big you know big day nerves right
but then the next time something happens
like they're going to bring this up
again this is a pattern this is a
pattern yeah they definitely swept it
under the rug yesterday but they're not
going to forget they're not going to
forget that quickly when I tell you like
I actually had tears in my eyes like I
can't even talk about it it was so sad
that's really like my bed is crunching
no I know it was really
sad would have been better or worse if
he fell
worse like for sure but the funny thing
is is like they were playing it in slow
motion and his leg like crossline and he
knew you know he knew he like it was
really it was one of the most tragic
things I've ever seen on television I'm
so sorry it's okay they don't tell you
that about football no they they don't
tell you about like the immense sadness
that comes with being a football fan who
also was just like a deeply you know I'm
an emotional person you know yeah and I
feel like The Men Who watch like they
don't wait into the emotional parts of
it no but like I think about that all
the time when it's like the game comes
down to a kick and the kicker doesn't
make it
yeah and it's so clear whose fault it is
that the game was lost cuz usually like
the whole team you know there were M
mistakes made throughout the game but
like when it's just on one person it's
too much for one person to bear I
agree I feel more that way in like
college football cuz then like the whole
school's mad at you at least profal
football like you can go home to your
family and like your friends but like in
college that's your whole life like
where do you go that's why that's why
it's really so important I think this is
a lesson for everyone it's like not give
everything to your job you know it's so
important to have like a full life at
home too because things will go wrong at
work whether you work you know in an
arena where millions of people are
watching or you just work at you know a
store like things are going to happen
and that's why it's so important to have
like a full life at home or things
outside of work because work will not
fulfill you no and when they turn on you
which they will because we're all humans
we're not perfect you're going to do
something imperfect in the workplace
like you need a refuge you need a refuge
and that's I'm sure what Taylor was for
Travis last night 100% oh yeah he had a
bad day at work yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story whoa which
wasn't meant to be our fifth but I wound
up moving you know the front Academy
Awards um Billy Alish is firing back at
questions about her sexuality she said I
like boys and girls leave me alone about
it
so Billy ish was kind of like taking on
variety after an interview and then
another interview and then posting to
her Instagram a picture of well it's a
carousel but the first picture I think
is like of her pants while she's on the
toilet because do you see it I'm I'm on
my way like I think she's trying to send
a message about the belt but I'm pretty
sure it's her pants on the toilet just
that's like a like a crazy angle to take
a photo of like that's that's like an
angle that's really only meant for your
eyes no it's a very like I know like
people post everything on the internet
now yeah she's on the toilet for sure
she's on the toilet but she's trying I
think she's trying to make a statement
about the belt CU it's like two women
crawling towards one another oh oh yeah
yeah yeah and then the caption says
thanks variety for my award and for also
outing me on a red carpet at 11:00 a.m.
instead of talking about anything else
that matters I like boys and girls leave
me alone about it please literally who
cares stream what was made for so she
did an interview with variety where she
talked about how she likes girls and
then she was at an event for a variety
and they asked her about that
question that statement she had made in
in the interview the statement that she
made in the interview and she said um in
uh the interview she said I never really
felt like I could relate to girls very
well and I love women so much I love
them as people I'm attracted to them as
people I'm attracted to them for real
and then on the carpet they they asked
if she had intended to come out in the
issue and she said no I didn't I kind of
thought wasn't it obvious I didn't
realize people didn't know she said she
doesn't really believe in coming out I'm
just like why can't we just exist I've
been doing this for a long time and I
just didn't talk about it whoops so then
she said like thanks for outing me on
the carpet so I'm like always the first
one to blame the publication you know I
feel like they're sneaky and bad
intended you know bad faith actors if
you will
MH however like I'm really not
understanding why she's mad yeah cuz she
said what she said in her interview and
for a lot of people that's fabulous news
go people that was the first time that
they knew same so then that was the
outage right and then they asked how did
the outage go and she said I didn't
intend to be
outed yeah
I'm but then she also like doesn't seem
mad about it I'm not sure I can't get a
read on her tone in this caption so it's
important to keep that in mind I think
maybe she's not mad and then also she
was on the
toilet and then there's the toilet part
and the toilet we'll get to we'll get to
the toilet being the Hallmark picture of
the carousel so it's you know I want to
flush variety down the toilet energy
it's giving variety sinks right yeah poo
poo variety poo poo variety is what
she's saying I think but also hey look
at my
belt but also hey look at my belt
there's a lot going on here and I'm not
an expert like I'm not going to be able
to like fully transcribe this for you
guys however what I will say is it's
giving hey look at my belt it is so you
also see her outfit on the carpet I did
and I didn't understand it but I'm
really not like a fashionable person you
know I'm wearing leggings so I again I'm
not going to try and and Translate like
this for everyone yeah she was also at
the LACMA Academy red carpet oh let me
go look at her look there cuz that's
where everyone wore their best threads
it wasn't um it was not my favorite but
I just want to see like what era she's
in you know cuz she like she commits
yeah oh I think she's in this sort of
like
androgynous era if I were to guess yeah
but this is a
sea it's a sea but it's kind of like a a
masculine seam LW don't you think like
with the yes because it's a Blazer pin
stripe yeah but there's
breasts there there is
breasts the thing is Billy ish is a
creative and she's an artist and she's
also a young girl growing up right in
front of our eyes so I think we're going
to see her through these um eras if you
will you know stylistically and and
creatively so I think maybe she's in you
know I don't know she yeah she's trying
new things she's trying new things you
new Styles I do AG I I guess I think I I
actually know what she was trying to say
um with but it came off sounding like
rude and like she was mad but I think
what she was trying to say is like it
shouldn't have to be that you have this
like big Affair when you come out like
love who you love whatever I think
that's really what she was trying to say
but it came off like a little
pretentious like she was like yelling at
people yeah I think that was like half
of what she was trying to say which is
like I don't want to have to come out
like this is just who I am but then also
publiced her at 11: a.m. right at 11
a.m. nonetheless which it's oh no it's
past 11:00 a.m. now yeah this has been a
nice long episode yeah I mean it's
Monday and do saw pet psychic so of
course we have a lot to talk about we
have a lot to break down so it starts
and ends with the pet psychic yeah tell
her that Bruno is not happy maybe she
can sense that maybe she can sense
it she definitely it but Bruno's
feelings are hurt he said Mom I'm just a
lover I said I know Brew I know your
intentions but it's intention versus
impact and you're eating his and you're
eating his food and you're sitting on
his couch the pet psychic said that she
felt like Bruno was a bad faith
actor that's what she said if and that's
where I'll leave it I'll stand up for my
boy till the end that's our show you
guys thank you so much for listening to
the toast of millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere anywhere podcast can be
found that's Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I Radio cast box all the
places wherever you listen to podcast
find us the toast leave five star you
bet our beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are have an amazing Monday
we'll see you on Tuesday hashd doong
hash look at my belt love you bye
bye